during a winter night in warsaw
hundreds of protesters came out to the
streets to tell the government that they
think
its stance on abortion is wrong
enough is enough we demand solidarity
from you we demand solidarity
on wednesday night poland's new abortion
law went into immediate effect
banning terminations of pregnancies with
fetal abnormalities
abortions will now only be allowed in
cases of rape and incest
or if the mother's life is at risk
doctors performing illegal abortions
will face jail time
i want us to have our basic rights the
right to decide about our bodies
the right to decide what we want to do
and if we want to bear children and in
what circumstances to have children
i do not want to get pregnant one day
and see my child
die after birth this thought horrifies
me
the ruling led to weeks of much larger
nationwide protests in october
because of this the conservative law and
justice party delayed its implementation
of the law
the abortion law is in line with other
policies from the right-wing party
since taking office in 2015 it has also
ended state funding for in vitro
fertilization
this predominantly catholic country now
has one of the most conservative laws on
abortion
in europe there are fewer than 2 000
legal abortions every year
but women's groups estimate that an
additional 200 000 women
either abort illegally or abroad leah
harding
al jazeera